vous avez évoqué pas mal de chroniquer
en ai pas parlé de votre salaire vous
avez aussi donner votre avis sur les
chroniqueurs de tp et notamment sur
gilles way regarder chez chroniqueurs
qui en fait trop jeu vers 2 c'est vrai
que il est toujours un peu d'emphase
raconter des anecdotes comme si c'était
des trucs un creux qui lui arrive et
voilà il a une manière de raconter que
son rôle mais qui du coup en font à
chaque fois des anecdotes incroyables
et puis la façon de tout sur jouer un
peu voilà il joue pas mais pensez - si
georges ou quand il donne également
comme ça dans la vie
maintenant ce que je fais pardon gilles
ci ne regarde mais voilà je suis
persuadé que quand ils en boîte de nuit
dans ce pas comme ça on quand ils
dansent au plateau danse comme ça je
pense que quand il chante dans sa salle
de bain ils chantent pas aussi faut
qu'ils chantent à l'antenne qu'est ce
que j'avais à dire je me lui répondre
quelles que soient les conséquences
ah oui calmez vous quand même il ya
pascal le grand frère et l'opa de
l'échauffourée du show là bas il est
chaud plus ont bondi au dialogue
tu viens de plus que moi on en branle en
pas une passe encore si ça vous semble
incroyable
[Applaudissements]
quoique cette question d'ancienneté
rempile à paris deux fois lille de
conneries non non non c'est un des
meilleurs
ce mec mais que ce mec qui n'en branle
pas une pour sétois jean michel regardez
vous surveillez votre langage femmes le
cg personne qui ne fait rien pour
l'émission nous donne des leçons de
journalisme nous disent oui alors vous
n'êtes pas tout à fait naturel etc
ça fait des mois jean-michel que tu nous
emmerdes avec ta bouche que tu vas faire
au théâtre
nous avons fait chier avec ça ils
demandent des jeudis dès vendredi va me
loue pas possible mais t'es pas capable
d'articuler trois mots tu vas nous
emmerder sur eux
[Applaudissements]
bien
[Rires]
qu'est ce que c'est qu'ils ont
entièrement raison pas ses jambes il est
vraiment bon joueur en attendant les
producteurs de théâtre isabelle gens me
et pas perdre aise
ouais mais bon on est bon s'il est trop
chaud quelque chose s'il ya des
producteurs de théâtre qui veulent
perdre beaucoup d'argent
ces beautés mal quand même c'est vrai